WITH THAT TASK.
2-0 AS A STAR.
MAKES HIS HOME I A PROBLEM, TOO.
THEY NEED THOSE  A CHECK ON ON
UNTIL THE STARS TOUCH IT BIZARR.
HE DRILLED HIMSELF INTO THE POST
WHEN HE LOST HIS TRIED TO GET I
BACK.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME FINE IS
JUST AN
WRISTER OFF OF CAMPBELL.
KLINGBERG DRAGS IT WITH RILEY.
WRISTED BY THE STARS TO THE
LINE.
KEPT IN BY
SEASON FOR THIS MAPLE LOAVES
CLUB.
DEEP FULLY UP TO
SPEED IN BOTHSLOT.
NOW THAT GETS PLUCKED.
HE JUST DROVEAS SOME FRESH LEGS
MOVES IT TO MATTHEWS.
BACK FOR GIORDANO.
MATTHEWS  THE STARS PENALTY KILS
GIORDANO, THE LEADATH IT, OUT O
PLAY IT GO
THREAD IT ACROSS TO SUTER.
HEISKANEN FOR PAVELSKI.
IN THE MIDST OF A CHANGEDEFENDI
STAYED IN THE A DOUBLE CLUTCH.
LEAPS ACROSS THE LINE. MUCH REA
WEDGEWOOD TOR AWAITS IT.
THE LEAFS SCRAMBLING IN
THEIR OWN  HEIR STICK F WAY TO E
BACK OF THE NET.
TIED AT ONE AFTER ONE. USED CAM
SECOND TIME.
>> Daryl: IT IS AND GONE.
AUSTON MATTHEWS EVER DANGEROUS.
HE'S